لديك خبرين هذا الصباح ماذا عن عوده
البريد
مرحبا ليث ومرحبا ما عارفه اذا سمر معك او
لا لكن
عوده ساعي البريد يسعد صباحكم بالخير
منورين والله ومبارك لصباح العربيه هذه
الفقره
عوده ساعي البريد في السودان كانت في
العام 2017
بمبادره ذاتيه من صانع المحتوى مصطفى فزع
ومن ثم قادها طلاب بالجامعات السودانيه
المختلفه هي في الحقيقه دعم لهؤلاء الطلاب
ممن يمتلك منهم مهاره في فن الكتابه وفن
الخط العربي والرسم ايضا وايضا بشرى ساره
لعشاق الرسائل الورقيه والذين يدركون
خصوصيتها الجماليه والمعنويه حقيقه سلبت
منها وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي وايضا
الهواتف عموما متعه تبادل الرسائل الورقيه
توقف هؤلاء الشباب
منذ عام 2017 لكن يعودون الان من جديد فهي
بشرى ساره لعشاق الرسائل يطمحون في فتح
مكاتب ايضا خارج السودان هم الان يمتلكون
مكاتب مختلفه في ولايات السودان المختلفه
بالعوده للتاريخ اول ساعه بريد في السودان
هو ابراهيم ود الفراش وفي هذا الشهر
بالتحديد شهر مارس من اواخر تسعينيات
القرن قبل الماضي كانت اول طوابع بريد في
السودان وكانت في مكاتب للبريد بولايات
السودان المختلفه وكانت هنالك المكاتب
بالخرطوم ودنقله وبربر
وعدد من المدن والمناطق الريان بعد قليل
ان شاء الله يتم الاعلان عن هلال شهر
رمضان نريد ان اسالك ماذا عن الدراما
السودانيه اليوم شو هي العناوين العريضه
للدراما السودانيه اليوم
طيب حقيقه يعني تشهد يعني او يشهد هذا
الموسم في رمضان تنافس درامي غير مسبوق في
تاريخ الدراما في السودان لطالما كانت
دراما السودانيه هي الحاضره الغائبه
لطالما هجر المشاهد السوداني القنوات
المحليه لقنوات اخرى بحثا عن دراما
يتابعها واحتلت دراما العربيه القنوات
السودانيه لسنوات طويله وظل المشاهد
السوداني يتمسك باعمال دراميه قديمه قابعه
في الاذهان نحن نتحدث عن مسلسل الذهبايه
مسلسل ذكين اقمار الضواحي وغيرها من
المسلسلات لكن رمضان هذا العام او دعيني
وكلا يمل ونحب نكون طول اكتر معك ولكن
للاسف الوقت يداهمنا احيانا كانت معنا
ريان الظاهر مراسل صباح العربيه من
الخرطوم السودان